we are hyped for the return of
ghostbusters especially since we know
they had Aykroyd and Bill Murray are
signed on but it seems like another og
has joined the ghost hunt back for
Ghostbusters Ghostbusters what do you
want I'm so old I could have forgotten
that I was in it I feel like oh my god
was I in that Andy's already shot her
scenes for the movie due out next year
but could she have another reboot in the
works
designing woman's on who you know yes we
were the original whoa girls if the idea
we did it that's important you know
female coming honoree
I feel like that could work and if that
kind of thing could work I would be
there the 67 year old has a knack for
picking parts that stand the test of
time along with some iconic fashion
moment Corvette summer with mr. mark
Haines well I was playing a prostitute
and that was one of my prostitute looks
it was pretty good run it yeah hi
pretty in pink this dress was actually
made of rubber which looked awesome
but a girl couldn't really move in it
that's thrilling last but certainly not
least I mean more that's the worst
picture of me I ever saw that looks like
somebody doing drag of me
no young sheldon's meemaw has a new love
interest this season but her favorite
people to work with are still her
youngest co-stars I love the children
they're so sweet
they're like little ferrets they're just
they're everywhere all over that set
[Music]